what is the research fellowship program
and how it works so
practically speaking how it works so the
research fellowship program is unique
because it's really designed to offer
you a
supportive community with very practical
outcomes
and so you can see here some examples of
poster presentations
about the different types of programs as
well as some of the projects that have
been submitted
individually or as group projects
and so to help facilitate the process
of going from learning bioinformatics to
actually applying bioinformatics to big
data
and getting results we designed this
kind
of a process that helps anyone
without previous practical knowledge of
bioinformatics if you've known about
bioinformatics you understand what it is
you can get started
and then get all the way to this outcome
right so the question is how
and the way we did it is we started
developing
exemplar projects from peer-reviewed
papers
that cover a variety of topics including
epigenetic regulation of asthma or
precision medicine using cell line
models and artificial intelligence
how to apply deep sequencing
technologies to understand viral
replication
how to study the changing landscape of
our of the ecology and understand how we
can intervene
how to understand the immune responses
in cancer
how to study the microbiome of
individuals that are scattered around
the world
and understand what factors are
affecting the microbiome
how to study these animal
patient-derived
xenograft models or pdx models where you
can study cancer
coming from a human in an animal model
how to apply the understanding of big
data to
tcga the cancer genome atlas that
represents
thousands of patients from different
types of cancers
how to apply bioinformatics and
biotechnology and
understand the production of biologics
including vaccines and different kinds
of
large proteins that are used for
treatment of specific diseases
or even how to apply analysis of
transatomic data to understand
the crop drought stress and resistance
and different
cultivars of potato how to understand
the complex gene regulation in
neurodegenerative diseases
or understand outbreaks of infectious
pandemics like the ebola outbreak
of 2014-2016 but
the range of topics doesn't end there
and so that's why
we also provide you with an opportunity
to start from scratch and design
a project that is completely
individually picked by you
so we have a system that can help you
find a topic understand what type of
data
could be used to study that topic and
how to ask a specific
tech a specific technical question that
could be answered with data analysis
and then how to go through the process
of designing a research project
on your own in groups and with the help
of
a mentor so the way this works
is that we have a program that is
designed to
help you understand through the
introduction
evaluate your progress through practice
and then start applying these different
analysis skills to a data set
of your own and along the way interact
with our community through weekly
progress reports
on slack as we interact with each other
and have a whole community that can
discuss
a variety of topics but also through
access to mentorship and i will talk
about that in just a few moments
but first let's talk about the
introduction so as a part of getting you
started it's important to get
a broad perspective widen your horizon
and understand the application of
bioinformatics to big data that is
widely available and that includes
coursework that you can complete
asynchronously on the introduction
on and on different types of omix
technologies genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and gain practical skills and data
science including
machine learning statistical analysis
coding and r and python
as well as fair practices to
make your analysis reproducible which is
a critical
important skill to have if you are going
into research or even if you're going
into industry
ultimately after that you get an
opportunity to
use our omixlogic portal to develop
and submit your project and get feedback
along the way and so the process that we
have is that first of all you have to
earn
a certain number of points you have to
update your profile and really
create a profile that you can share and
then go through these steps to start
submitting a project
and so when you submit that project you
can actually
upload all of the information that is
needed
and then complete your profile adding
some information about your background
adding social media links to your
linkedin or potentially to org id
and really being ready for submitting a
project and sharing
it with the world and so after you go
through that
you will also get access to a whole
course
on how to submit a project that is
impactful
and that will be evaluated by experts
from the bioinformatics community
what you gain out of this process is
ability to understand how
others have applied bioinformatics to
different types of studies through
literature review you get to become an
investigator
which is what people do in research but
also in industry they
know how to ask questions and answer
those questions with data
and also you get the ability to write
and prepare
the project for the presentation so that
you
get a good result you get an impactful
presentation that you can share with
experts in the field
the way that this happens is through a
defined series of steps
first by identifying a competitive topic
in an area of research that others are
interested in
number two by finding data sets which
you will get guidance on
number three to summarize your data and
prepare
a summary of what does the metadata
describe about the data that you found
conducting exploratory analysis
then doing in-depth analysis biological
interpretation
and then you start interaction with your
mentor the peers
and experts and so that's where the
community comes in so all throughout
this process we have
weekly sessions and at the end once
you've gotten the feedback from the
mentor the experts and the community
you actually start working on your
project presentation so that project
presentation
also follows a number of defined steps
that everybody follows both in research
and in your
university studies right you have to
essentially build a project that will
describe
what have you done what are the findings
and what is the significance of those
findings for the field that you are in
whether it's data science whether it is
neuroscience
precision medicine agriculture
biotechnology etc
the field needs to know why they should
be paying attention to your project
and how does your analysis contribute to
answering some of the gaps
in current research or answering
questions about
how to utilize methods to address gaps
that will come
in the future and so i think that this
program is unique because it really
provides us with
unique outcomes that are guaranteed
so what are some of the guaranteed
outcomes number one
you will definitely learn about the
challenges and the opportunities
in bioinformatics as a whole so in many
cases when we talk to students
that are either undergraduate or in
graduate master degree programs
they have a theoretical understanding of
bioinformatics but they don't understand
how
they can apply bioinformatics to address
a specific challenge
or whether what they are doing is going
to be meaningful and needed
in a particular field number two many
don't have the practical training
to be able to independently work with
data sets and so that's where training
and skill development comes in but it's
only
one part of the program not the full
program
number three you can work on independent
or group
research projects so you can really work
on a project that you
found a data set that you're interested
in or even
join the program before you identify a
data set and a question
and learn how to develop a question and
start finding that data set
but you can also work in groups so as we
mentioned we have about 50 people in the
different batches we have three
different batches
and also some other batches for high
school students that are later
in the day in the us and so that's when
you can
collaborate with others and learn how to
work together as a team
solving these interdisciplinary problems
then finally some
most ambitious people will go for a
poster presentation or
even a research publication and so in a
few minutes i will introduce you to some
of these outcomes
with practical examples who has done
this
so let's talk briefly about the specific
questions that we've had so number one
can this program
be used for the requirement of a
university internship
the answer is yes and by the way right
now
you're welcome to write any other
questions that you have
and i see that some of you are doing it
but i will address
all of these questions that you're
asking in the next few slides
so again number one can this program be
used for a requirement for university
internship
yes we have a number of amity
university uh participants and
participants from other universities
that are doing exactly that number two
what is the difference between
three and six months program the
difference is that if you are
wanting to actually publish it takes a
long time
and so even though we know you can do a
lot in three months
we would like you to understand that it
is a time consuming process
and i will talk a little bit about the
process
so that you really understand what is
the time commitment that is needed
so how many hours commitment does the
research fellowship require
so the research fellowship is flexible
and is highly dependent on your
commitment
personally if you want to get the most
out of this we recommend
spending at least 10 to 15 hours per
week
on your research project which includes
just one to two hours for a weekly
meeting
it also includes about an hour a day
to go through the different learning
materials that are needed
so remember i said in total 15 10 to 15
hours
so if you just spend one hour a day
that's seven hours
plus about two to three hours per week
for interaction with your mentor and
with the whole group so that's about 10
hours
some people need more than an hour they
also need additional time to do
literature review
and perform their own analysis so that's
why we estimate it to be between 10
and 15 hours per week what are the
mentorship
options so i will go through some of the
mentorship options you can
use our team as your mentors but also
we'll introduce you to some of the
advanced mentorship options that you can
choose from
can we choose any topic yes you can find
a topic that
we will help you identify you can refine
that topic
during your interaction with the mentor
and then you can develop
a full research proposal around that
topic
can you work in group projects yes you
can
the way to work in group projects is to
communicate with your mentor
and bring together that team or ask for
an introduction so we
can definitely help you with that can
you publish
yes and we have some examples that i
will show you in a few minutes
and then finally pricing payment options
and scholarships and so i will get to
that
just let me give a little bit more
detail about
some of these first questions so first
of all here's an example
here's an example of a research project
and i want to briefly talk about how do
you get from
a topic that seems interesting to
actually
finishing that project and submitting it
as a publication this is an example
from one of our programs with university
of ghana
where we had a whole lab join this
project
and bring their own data to
complete some number of publications in
six months so during the six months we
first of all
helped design different project ideas
and turn them
into bioinformatics research that has
some additional competitiveness to it
by including methods of analysis that
previously the lab was not exposed to
so then we refined those proposals
and going through several internal
presentations
created posters and this is an example
of a poster that we presented together
with the team
at one of the research conferences
during that time
we got some feedback and now we are
working on
turning that feedback into a full
journal present
journal publication for peer review so
that whole process takes at least six
months
right but in the process
a lot has been achieved in three months
and so here are some examples of people
that just did three months and what are
the outcomes for them
so one of our graduates is urja park who
in the course of three months submitted
a project
did her presentation at different
conferences but also
developed a full publication that later
on was submitted to
bioarchive andres
is a high school student that completed
his training
developed a research proposal and now is
going for a competition
that he is going to participate in
here's another participant that actually
used his experience
to participate in a hackathon and then
went on to
receive prizes during a hackathon and
also we have
others that have participated in these
and actually
uh got into other types of programs as a
result of their experience
so really those are the different
outcomes you can do a poster
presentation
you can join a competition you can also
get prizes from different competitions
because of the training
or you might be going for a phd or a
master's program so it's going to be
easier for you to get accepted
if you show that you have the necessary
background
okay so as i mentioned some of the
outcomes could be certificates in
different presentations that you do
or even submission a of a preprint
like you see right here others have
also went on to publish for example
see maidulana here actually submitted
her uh
for her uh to a publication uh on
in the columbia undergraduate science
journal
and so there's a publication option but
of course we cannot guarantee that we
can only guarantee that we will help you
but you will have to go for an actual
publication so this is the publication
that she got
others actually use this in their phd
uh programs so for example olgo
she's a research affiliate postdoc at
roswell park comprehensive cancer center
and as a result of her training she was
able to apply the same methods to her
research
both pre-clinical and ideas about
clinical
research another student a phd student
at louisiana state university went
through the coursework
as a part of her university requirements
if you're a high school student we also
have a number of high school students
that have
participated in the different programs
that we have and actually designed
a project as you can see right here to
get some
awards at a science fair
here's an example of a student from
georgetown university systems medicine
master degree program
so especially if you are interested in
applying to different
programs at universities this is
relevant as well
you can get a lot of benefit by learning
additional information about the
new topics like machine learning here's
another phd student that we have
had previously in a program so actually
as a part of his thesis
he used the program to work on his
thesis
and interact with the mentors okay
number two i see a lot of questions that
come up
about mentorship so for the summer
we have a great panel of expert mentors
that
have phd's in relevant fields
that have mastered degrees in relevant
fields and that are very
interested to work with students not
only can you work on an
independent project you can also
get their guidance on projects that are
impactful from their perspective right
and this is critical because
they are already working on important
research topics
and they can get you involved in those
projects
so beyond just working independently you
can actually
know what it's like to work in a high
level
expert lab guided by a mentor that is
already accomplished that has the
publications
that can actually guide you through the
steps that they have been through
and so dr harpreet kaur has numerous
publications in bioinformatics and
cancer
dr sona vasudevan is a professor and
program director and expert in systems
medicine
clinton coonha has a master's degree in
molecular medicine and a master's degree
in bioinformatics
dr gio chavis has a phd in
bioinformatics and an
expert in neurodegenerative diseases and
glioblastoma
sahil sathya is a phd student in
bioinformatics big data
and is working on covet and health
disparities
and dr laura harris is a program
director and has a phd in bioinformatics
and is an expert in microbiology and we
have others in our network as well
so to gain that high level expertise
you can also design a proposal get
feedback from them
but also then have their guidance on how
to make the most out of your proposal
and when i say we have a broader network
we have been working with a number of
very experienced
uh ex with high level experts in
different domains
that have evaluated our approach in our
system
and they could also be an example and
potentially guide you
if we find the appropriate fit so
what are these resources that can help
you
get into the program and understand how
it works
before you commit let me ask you
um at this time to uh
go to our portal and i want to kind of
show you around
on how you can get started with this
process okay
so the first thing that we want to do is
we want to go to
learn.omixlogic.com and i will briefly
introduce you
to some of the topics that are covered
and where you can